[Musique]
j'aime bien ce salon histoire de lire à
Versailles d'abord parce que c'est un
salon qui est très apprécié par les
amoureux de l'histoire donc
comme j'écris beaucoup de livres
d'histoire je crois que j'ai fait 11
tonnes de Secrets d'histoire le j'ai
sorti les secrets du lycée donc le
public c'est que quand je viens c'est
avec des livres d'histoire et là on a
fait un livre d'histoire contemporaine
avec la Grande Duchesse du Luxembourg et
c'était l'occasion pour nous et de
parler à 300 personnes et puis ensuite
de signer notre livre
[Musique]
c'est raconté 40 ans d'amour entre le
grand-duc la Grande Duchesse il se
trouve que je suis franco-luxembourgeois
et que ce sont aussi mes souverains et
donc j'ai beaucoup de liens avec eux
depuis depuis que je suis tout gamin
donc
voilà je dis pas que j'ai été là oui
pour leur mariage il y a 40 ans c'est
l'avantage de vie mais donc c'est plutôt
sympathique de raconter comme ça de
l'intérieur ce qui s'est passé il y a 40
ans et de les avoir suivis depuis 40 ans
surtout
[Musique]
on découvre leur vie leur vie assez
étonnante c'est une cette vie se découpe
c'est 40 années se découpent en deux
parties une première partie 20 ans comme
grand-ducérité et ils ont fait beaucoup
de voyages ils ont représenté le pays et
puis 20 ans sur le trône a essayé de
justement de mettre en pratique les
idées qu'ils avaient professé quand ils
se sont jurés de s'aimer jusqu'à la fin
et qu'ils ont décidé de se marier
c'était pour
changer peut-être le regard qu'on
pouvait avoir et sur Luxembourg et sur
ce qui est une monarchie moderne c'est à
dire être utile aux autres être faire
des choses utiles notamment dans les
domaines culturels caritatif sociaux
humanitaires et c'est ce que font le
grand-duc et la Grande Duchesse en
permanence
[Musique]